es gibt ja sowas wie eine
Normalbiografie die Leute wollen sich
das Wohnen leisten können die wollen
eigentlich wollen immer noch viele auch
ein Häuschen sich irgendwie leisten
können die wollen von ihrer Arbeit leben
können und tatsächlich hat das etwas mit
Würde und auch was etwas mit dem
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden ja der Menschen
zu tun und der Ausbau der Sozialstaates
den wir gemeinsam so betrieben haben
also ich zeige jetzt gar nicht mit dem
Finger auf irgendeine Partei
der hat eben dazu geführt dass es sich
dass die Menschen immer öfter den
Eindruck haben es lohnt sich eben nicht
mehr sich anzustrengen es lohnt sich
nicht mehr zu arbeiten sich abzumühen
und das ist ein riesen Problem das ist
nicht nur Sprengstoff für unsere
Gesellschaft sondern es ist eben auch
etwas was uns im Augenblick davon abhält
auch noch mal durchzustarten und und
auch die Herausforderungen die wir haben
anzunehmen die Menschen sind nach der
Pandemie erschöpft das liegt so eine
immer noch so eine Art Grauschleier über
dem Land es ist so dass ist viele
psychische Erkrankungen psychosoziale
Belastung nicht nur bei und Jugendlichen
gibt auch bei Erwachsenen die Leute
finden sich überfordert sozusagen von
der Rush Hour des Lebens die Politik
kümmert sich um lauter Themen die total
uninteressant sind also
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das sind alles
Themen ehrlich gesagt da kann man drüber
reden da gibt es auch Gründe drüber zu
reden aber die Leute interessiert das
Null und das heißt wir haben eine
gesellschaftspolitische Debatte im Land
die völlig an den Menschen vorbei geht
und wir haben eine Politik die den
Beweis nicht mehr führt dass sie die
großen Probleme unseres Landes wirklich
löst und das macht die Leute die
Menschen haben Abstiegsängste und die
Menschen sind stark verunsichert weil
dieses System scheinbar nicht mehr in
der Lage ist die großen Herausforderung
zu lösen und das ist eine ganz
gefährliche Mischung und ich bin ganz
bei Ihnen über diese Themen müssen wir
reden und wir müssen gar nicht über die
AFD reden oder möglichst wenig über die
reden
zunächst eine Frage
ich bin kein Politiker und und habe
verstehe von Wirtschaft praktisch nichts
aber gibt es nicht eine Möglichkeit ich
fand diesen Vorschlag interessant dass
man sagt wir fangen mit der Besteuerung
erst sehr viel später an also ein
Einkommen bis 2000 Euro besteuern wir
überhaupt nicht dann haben wir plötzlich
einen Abstand zwischen dem Bürgergeld
und dem was verdient so teuer kann das
nicht sein wenn wir auf der anderen
Seite dann Wohngeld oder irgendetwas
bezahlen müssen was für die Leute ja
eine schon psychische absolute Belastung
das zweite was ich sagen wollte
wir müssen über die AFD reden das stimmt
nicht dass wir nicht über sie reden
müssen wir müssen nur ganz anders über
sie reden wir reden jetzt im Moment in
einer Art und Weise darüber dass wir sie
immer beschimpfen ja dass jeder sich
hinstellt und sagt das ist das
schlimmste was gibt und zwar ja es ist
das schlimmste was es gibt aber das
bringt überhaupt nichts sondern wir
müssen es anders machen wir müssen uns
anschauen
welche Forderungen welche echten
Forderungen die AFD steht und dann
müssen wir diese Forderungen mal
durchdiskutieren also wenn ich darf
machen wir mal ein Beispiel
höcke sagt beispielsweise als Björn
höcke sagt beispielsweise die
der Ukraine Krieg geht uns nichts an
da sollen wir nichts mehr tun wenn wir
dort nichts mehr tun haben wir hier
weder eine Energiekrise noch eine
Inflation
man muss sich anschauen was das wirklich
bedeutet und und das den Leuten erzählen
und das finde ich richtig also
im Moment ermittelt die Europäische
Union mit mit einer
diese Justiz Agenturen
wegen vollkommen Mord und wenn man diese
Berichte liest wird einem wirklich
schlecht also Massen Vergewaltigung von
Frauen Männern von Mädchen und Jungen
selbst von Kleinkindern
Kastration von männlichem
von
Privathäusern von
lebensmitteleinrichtung selbst von
Leichen die die Menschen bestatten
wollen
20.000
verschleppte Kinder und gleichzeitig
eine Änderung der russischen Gesetze
dass diese Verschleppung legalisiert
wird ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
ein Mensch dem das Wort Menschlichkeit
noch irgendetwas bedeutet an den Punkt
sagt nee ist mir egal sollen die selber
mit zurechtkommen müssen wir keine Hilfe
leisten es mag Menschen geben bei denen
das so ist die sind nicht mehr zu retten
die können wir nie überzeugen nicht mehr
die AFD zu gehen aber wenn wir das
machen was so jemand wie hört gefordert
dann ist das das Ergebnis dass wir
einfach sagen uns völlig egal vielleicht
ein zweites Beispiel
Alexander Krah sagt wir müssen der
Europäischen Union den Stecker ziehen
Björn höcke sagt dasselbe in einem
Interview nur noch ekelhafter diese
Europäische Union muss sterben damit das
wahre Europa leben kann ich möchte dass
wir uns hinsetzen und uns anschauen was
das wirklich heißt nicht dass das
schrecklich ist oder sowas sondern was
es heißt das würde heißen wenn die
Bundesrepublik aus der Europäischen
Union Austritt das ist die Europäische
Union nicht mehr gibt das ist dasselbe
wie wenn Frankreich oder Italien
austreten würde und das in dem Moment
alle Länder ihre Zölle hochfahren um
ihre eigene Wirtschaft zu schützen wir
sind aber die Wirtschaft die am meisten
von exportiert das würde bedeuten dass
am nächsten Tag die deutsche Wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen würde das würde bedeuten
dass wir Massenarbeitslosigkeit haben
und dass wir die Renten nicht mehr
bezahlen können das Strom würde bedeuten
dass wir sehr schnell in
größten Verwerfungen in diesem Land sind
die bis hin zu Revolution gehen können
ich möchte also an dieser Stelle
dass die Arbeitgeberverbände dass die
Gewerkschaften dass die
Familienunternehmen das Konzernchef das
klarmachen deutlich machen was das
bedeutet so eine Forderung wir treten
aus der EU aus und ich glaube dass man
so die Leute davon überzeugen kann nicht
die AFD zu gehen
der andere Weg dass wir immer sagen die
AFD ist das schlimmste was es gibt das
stimmt zwar aber interessiert keinen
Menschen niemand hat interessiert von
den Wählern von Trump
alles gemacht niemand hat interessiert
dass die Washington Post
20.000 Lügen von Trump aufgedeckt hat
also wohlgemerkt niemand von den Wählern
von Trump die anderen Leute haben das
durchaus interessiert also damit kommt
man nicht weiter sondern man muss die
Forderung der AFD Friedrich Merz und
sagt wir sind die AFD mit Substanz
wir sind die Alternative für mit
Substanz
nicht dazu geeignet wäre ihn so zu
interpretieren dass man ihm unterstellt
er würde in irgendeiner Weise da eine
Alternative mit Substanz das ist ja das
ist doch klar aber er hat natürlich
gemeint wir sind er hat wenn man gerade
bei diesem Satz er hat ja was er gemeint
hat wir sind die wahre Alternative
gegenüber dieser Bundesregierung und
natürlich nicht Alternative für
Deutschland mit Substanz Alternative für
Deutschland
sind wir ja auch wir sind nämlich die
Alternative für für die nächste
Bundesregierung und ähm das ganz anderes
ist und wenn
das Zitat ist wir sind die Alternative
für Deutschland mit Substanz und das ist
natürlich klar was gemeint ist aber
Alternative für Deutschland
klug aber ihn zu unterstellen er würde
damit in irgendeiner Weise eine Nähe zur
AFD Programm
ich würde es ist ganz schwierig wie ich
das kurz sagen dafür ist es ganz immer
schwer für eine Partei wenn sie
permanent den Vorsitzenden erklären muss
wenn sie immer wieder sagen muss wie das
eigentlich gemeint hat und aus meiner
Sicht verbietet es sich für die CDU so
eine Formulierung zu sagen Alternative
für Deutschland eben können ja alles
mögliche einfallen und warum überhaupt
die sind die christdemokratische Union
und da das hat einen großen Wert warum
muss ich mich an einem der der Gegner
abarbeiten wenn
es ist Anbieter nie so ja ich glaube
nicht an dass er sich
angegliedert hat was die Partei betrifft
die AFD sondern an deren Anhänger und er
hat ja noch ein Vorlauf es hatte dann
als über ihr Programm gesprochen haben
war ja schon abgekürzt worden Agenda für
Deutschland also die AFD dann die
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
und dann kam das Interview wo er nicht
klargestellt hatte dass es eine das ist
keine Zusammenarbeit zwischen Union und
FDP geben darf
davor gab es im Moment wenn man sagt auf
Bundesebene sind die Grünen
in der Bundesregierung
in der Bundesregierung hat er gesagt
es war vor allem es war vor allem nach
der Wahl des ersten
afd-politikers zum Landrat und dann in
diesem Zusammenhang sozusagen genau und
in diesem Zusammenhang sich auf die
Grünen zu lenken das ist eben alles sehr
unglücklich und ich habe in diesen
Nachklapp mit
CDU-Politikern gesprochen die
mehrere Jahre die CDU von innen auch mit
bestimmt und geprägt haben und sehr gut
vergleichen können zwischen der früheren
Vorsitzenden Kanzlerin Angela Merkel bis
heute zu märz und der sagte da sagte mir
einer Herr Merz also er hält ihn für
absolut unverdächtig mit der AFD
koalieren zu wollen aber er hat gesagt
er legt die rechte Hand auf den Herd und
merkt den Schmerzen nicht und ich finde
das trifft es ganz gut
er will etwas Kluges etwas Gutes sagen
und ihm passiert genau das Gegenteil und
wenn sie muss sich überlegen es war ein
sommerinterview mit dem
Oppositionsführer und man hat so gedacht
so jetzt reden wir ganz viel über den
Bundeskanzler was der nicht alles was
der alles falsch macht und wir haben
eine Woche komplett über
diesen Fauxpas des CDU-Vorsitzenden
geredet und wenn man sich die Zahlen
danach anguckt die Union steht jetzt in
Umfragen bei 26
27%, das Herr märz die AFD mal halbieren
wollte und ist nicht geschafft hat ist
das eine dass die AFD jetzt sagt wir
halbieren die Union das hat ja äh es ist
ja gar nicht mal lustig sondern
profitieren ja überhaupt nicht davon mit
diesem Namen zu spielen oder mit dieser
Partei zu spielen und insofern bin ich
sehr bei Ihnen eine inhaltliche
Auseinandersetzung aber ohne die ganze
Zeit zu sagen die AFD sagt das und das
und deswegen wollen wir das so und so
sondern einfach die Themen zu machen
genau und das ist aber noch ein bisschen
was anderes das ist ja noch ein bisschen
etwas anderes als das was sie
vorschlagen ich glaube Sie haben Recht
man muss sie man muss die inhaltlichen
Angebote der AFD tatsächlich
dekonstruieren und und
entlarven man muss aber und das ist
glaube ich noch wichtiger man muss auf
die Dinge die die Menschen wirklich
belasten und
die da muss man bessere Antworten geben
na ja das machen wir ja also dass wir
versuchen es muss man sagen
muss man schon sagen
also ich könnte jetzt zynisch sein und
sagen wir wollten diese
abgewirtschafteten Bundesregierung mal
eine Woche Verschnaufpause in der
Sommerpause geben denn eigentlich hätte
man ja die ganze in den ganzen Sommer
über diese Bundesregierung sprechen
müssen da haben wir den jetzt mal ein
bisschen Zeit zum Durchatmen gegeben
aber okay das hat auch nicht geklappt
hat auch nicht so richtig genau und
darauf konnte man sich auch verlassen
dass es nicht klappen wenn nein aber das
ich will jetzt gar nicht zynisch sein
ich glaube einfach nur wir haben das ja
auch intern besprochen und dass das
nicht klug war das weiß doch Friedrich
Merz auch das ist ihm völlig klar ihn zu
unterstellen er hätte da irgendeine Nähe
das halte ich für absurd aber ich glaube
tatsächlich dass wir uns jetzt
ausschließlich mit den Themen
beschäftigen müssen und in den Dingen
die die Menschen wirklich bewegen das
sind zu hohe Energiepreise das ist
Inflation das ist Abstiegsangst das ist
die Frage kann ich meine Häuschen noch
halten im Zusammenhang mit dem mit dem
heizungsgesetz und solche Dinge das das
sind die Dinge die Menschen bewegen wir
haben über die Frage
Sozialstaat Verhältnis leistung muss
sich wieder lohnen Aldi das sind die
Themen über die wir sprechen müssen ich
glaube carsten nennemann hat da seitdem
er Generalsekretär ist auch gute
Vorstöße gemacht und manchmal vielleicht
ein bisschen zugespitzt aber ich glaube
das ist schon in die richtige Richtung
geht es ist auch dieser krawallige Sound
ne
ja das ist auch nicht mein Sound ist
nicht wie das was gerade von Schirach
hier vorgetragen hat immer dieser
krawallige Sound ja das kann man das ist
viel Populismus und wenn ich da ganz
kurz auf die Migrationsdebatte kommen
darf also der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer Thorsten frei plädiert
für die Abschaffung des individuellen
Asylrechts Herr Spahn
Bundestagsabgeordneter setzt einen oben
drauf und sagt wir brauchen eine Pause
das ist
zahlt alles bei der AFD ein und was mich
besonders daran erschreckt ist die
Abschaffung des Grundrechts auf Asyl des
individuellen Grundrecht auf Asyl würde
in den Zahlen überhaupt nichts bringen
ich habe mir die noch mal angeschaut
beim Bundesinnenministerium von 230.000
entschiedenen Anträgen im vergangenen
Jahr sind
0,8 Prozent Menschen 0,8% 1.900 Menschen
für die sich die Union oder für
wofür die Union eine Debatte losbricht
wo man dann zuerst denkt boah das ist
jetzt aber hart und das könnte das
könnte das könnte genauso von der AFD
kommen in wissen es bringt überhaupt
nichts wenn das passierte es würde auch
sie sie können es vor allem nicht
schaffen weil sie dafür keine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit im Bundestag bekommen
werden was bedeutet es ist dann wieder
so ja die kündigen oder die machen groß
Krawall und es kommt aber dann zu keinem
Ergebnis und das ist finde ich wirklich
der schlechteste Umgang mit der
Migrationspolitik da auf einen AFD
sprechen zu steigen und dann aber nicht
Entschuldigung nicht wirkliche Lösung zu
liefern denn ich
ist wirklich einmal sagen man kann ich
bin mit vielen mit der Tonalität bin ich
oft auch nicht einverstanden aber bei
der Frage des individual Grundrechtes da
geht es ja um die Frage welchen Anspruch
habe ich auf Prüfung es ist richtig dass
nur sehr wenige überhaupt in Anspruch
nehmen einen das Recht auf Asyl die
meisten wollen ja Schutz nach dem
verflüchtlingskomvention und so weiter
aber der Prüfungsmodus der ist ja
gegründet sich ja auf das individuelle
Grundrecht auf Asyl und deshalb betrifft
diese Vorschrift im Grundgesetz
natürlich nicht nur die 0,8 Prozent
sondern eigentlich alle die an die
Grenze kommen und sagen ich beantworte
Lösung finden
weitermachen darf ich Ihnen ein bisschen
widersprechen
es ist glaube ich noch ein bisschen
anders
individuelle
asylgrundrecht in der Bundesrepublik ist
praktisch ausgeruht ausgehöhe 16A spielt
gar keine Rolle mehr ja und alle diese
Fragen werden und müssen von der
Europäischen Union entschieden werden
und das ist ja auch das richtige so was
mich so geärgert hat ist dass man diese
Vorschläge überhaupt macht wenn man weiß
dass das dass das inhaltlich also es
geht mir nicht um die Anzahl der Leute
sondern das ist überhaupt nicht möglich
ist und das ist nichts bedeutet und dann
gibt es ja noch wir können ja noch einen
Schritt weitergehen wir können ja sagen
was ist denn das für eine Idee zu sagen
wir nehmen nur noch Kontingente auf also
kurz erklären ne also er sagt lass uns
das abschaffen und stattdessen
Kontingent Lösen
von 200 000
300.000 im Jahr aber was würde das ich
bin ganz sicher das funktioniert
genau
selbst wenn wir das sagen würden
ist es doch deshalb sinnlos so etwas zu
erklären weil ja die anderen Flüchtlinge
deswegen nicht doch auch kommen würden
es ist doch es ist doch nicht so sie
sind jetzt Flüchtling in Syrien und sie
wissen es werden aus Syrien jetzt 30.000
Leute aufgenommen werden Sie persönlich
wollen aber fliehen und gehören nicht zu
diesen 30.000 dann gehen sie doch
trotzdem los also schon die Idee des
Kontingenz ist funktioniert gar nicht
auf der anderen Seite wir brauchen einen
robusteren außengrenzenschutz denn das
das einzige das ist das einzige was
wirklich auch ein Signal an die Menschen
in aller Welt sendet wenn ihr einen
Anspruch auf politisches asylab wenn ihr
wegen Verfolgung aus religiösen oder
wegen
anderer Menschenrechtsfragen wenn ihr
verfolgt werde dann könnt ihr bei uns
aufgenommen werden aber wenn ihr kommt
weil ihr mit eurer Familie besser leben
wollt was ja total nachvollziehbares
Argument ist dann haben hier nicht alle
aufnehmen das ist ja das das ist das
Signal und das meint ja auch Thorsten
frei wenn er wenn er diesen Vorschlag
macht und die Frage des robusteren
außengrenzenschutz die steht ja im
Moment in der Europäischen Union in der
Verhandlung und natürlich ist es so dass
wir bisher es nicht geschafft haben dich
alle Bemühungen um Abschiebung und
Rückführung auch nur annähernd das
Problem zu lösen ich bin auch der feste
Überzeugung es wird uns nicht gelingen
wenn die Menschen einmal hier sind dann
wird es immer sehr sehr Schwierigkeiten
und wir brauchen aber eine Lösung wir
brauchen Migration es geht um die Frage
was etwas bringt und ich sag mal
WählerInnen Wähler durchschauen dass er
dann auch schnell und merken ja ganz
schnell so der die tun jetzt so als
würde das etwas bringen aber in Wahrheit
funktioniert das ein weiteres Mal nicht
und führt zu weiterer
Politikverdrossenheit Sie als Mitglied
der Union
die auch dieses zehennamen hat und jetzt
auch angesichts macht es mal ein
bisschen größer auch der deutschen
Geschichte und auch als Mitglied einer
Fraktion die erst kürzlich noch
festgestellt hat wir auch als
Unionsfraktion bekennen uns ausdrücklich
zum Grundrecht auf Asyl und das wäre
tatsächlich also das wäre ein echter
Paradigmenwechsel wie geht's Ihnen also
Recht darauf hingewiesen dass Grundrecht
auf Asyl ist ja durch die in den 90er
Jahren vorgenommen der
Verfassungsänderung weitgehend sozusagen
übertragen worden in europäisches Recht
also das muss man ja immer sagen und ich
was Thorsten freier sagen wollte ist wir
müssen
verfahrensrechtlich in der Situation
kommen wo wir nicht verpflichtet sind
jeden der sozusagen deutschen Boden
betritt dann auch so lange hier zu weit
dass man am Ende ja gar nicht mehr
wegschicken kann denn das wird ja immer
unmenschlicher wenn jemand 5 Jahre hier
ist auch wenn er keinen Anspruch auf
Asyl hat sondern nur eine Duldung hat
den dann irgendwann wieder zurückzusehen
diese deutschen Schicksale kennen wir
doch alle also muss das Ziel sein die
Menschen entweder wenn sie aus Ländern
kommen wo die schutzquote niedrig ist
sehr schnell an der europäischen Grenze
das Verfahren zu bearbeiten sie dann
zurückschicken zu können und dafür Sorge
zu tragen dass einfach weniger Menschen
nach Deutschland kommen und dieser
Vorschlag diente dazu in dieser Debatte
in Vorstoß zu machen ich fand ihn jetzt
ehrlich gesagt ich fand ihn gar nicht so
dumm
erklären müssen
Schritt weitergehen
man muss also die Lebenswirklichkeit
sich ja auch anschauen wie sie vorkommen
zu Recht gesagt haben was machen wir
denn wenn jemand da ist erstmal sagen
wir die ersten 15 Monate darfst du nicht
arbeiten
das ist ein kompletter Wahnsinn
stecken Sie ein 18-Jährigen Jungen oder
jungen Mann in ein Wohnheim und sagt
okay du bleibst jetzt mal 15 Monate
genau auf dem Platz sitzen das was soll
denn daraus werden das ist doch verrückt
ja und macht Unsinn und das ist auch
vollkommen nachzuvollziehen ich wäre
genauso
also wir müssen an der anderen Seite
genauso anfangen Dinge zu ändern und und
zwar schnell zu Ende und das kostet uns
nichts im Gegenteil ja und
dafür wurde ich plädiere ja ich glaube
dass die einzigen die das lösen können
ist wir alle gemeinsam das kann nur die
Europäische Union lösen und das kann nur
gelöst werden durch eine Prüfung an den
Außengrenzen und es kann nur gelöst
werden durch Verträge mit den
verschiedenen Staaten und das kann nur
die Europäische Union ist übrigens auch
etwas was man der AFD sagen muss wenn
man die abschafft sind wir vollkommen
alleine dann haben wir ein echtes
Problem aber aber wir müssen uns doch
oder wir müssen doch an der Stelle auch
zu ehrlich sein dass wir nicht
Vorschläge machen die von denen wir
beide wissen haben
Thorsten frei enthielt ja die Frage was
machen wir eigentlich mit der
Interpretation
des europäischen flüchtlingsrechts das
ist ja keinesfalls zwingend die
Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention so
auszulegen die Engländer legen sie ganz
anders aus also um Gottes Willen ich
will kein Ruanda Modell nicht dass das
ich will damit nur sagen nach Köln man
könnte sich natürlich auch auf
europäischer Ebene verständigen aber das
lassen wir uns das tun dann verständigen
wir uns auf europäischer eben das ist ja
auch zulässig das zu machen aber wir
können doch nicht also mir ging es so in
vielen Kollegen vielen Juristen die das
gelesen haben ist auch in den Zeitungen
stand es doch wirklich am nächsten Tag
dass das kein durchführbare Vorschlag
ist und und das ist ja ein intelligenter
Mann ich glaube er ist auch selbst
Jurist und weiß das vollkommen das ein
Vorschlag
aber ich glaube einfach nur
entschuldigen wenn ich dazu sagen ich
glaube einfach nur
ganz oft wird der Fehler gemacht
nicht nur aus der Politik das ist auch
beim Fernsehen zum Beispiel so wo ich wo
ich das oft genug erlebt habe dass die
Menschen für viel dümmer gehalten werden
als sie in Wirklichkeit sind und die
Menschen verstehen es sofort sie
kapieren das geht nicht und das ist ein
Vorschlag der funktioniert nicht und
wofür ich nur plädieren würde ist dass
wir Vorschläge machen die tatsächlich
funktionieren und über die können wir
dann von
gleichermaßen erwarten lassen Sie mich
das noch sagen dass sie gleichermaßen
erwarten ist das über dieses Thema
weniger moralisch und mehr mit Blick auf
Lösungen diskutiert wird und deshalb
kann man den Vorstand gerne verwerfen
aber man muss jetzt ganz konkret darüber
sprechen wie es uns gelingen kann
zumindest den Zuzug einzudämmen es geht
ja gar nicht darum zu sagen so zu uns
darf keiner mehr kommen das ist doch gar
nicht der Punkt
wir hatten
interessant heute von der Basis zu
Fragen die alle samt und sonders das
gleiche sagen die sagen wir können so
nicht weitermachen und auch deswegen
weil Migration und Integration vor allen
Dingen weit mehr ist als einfach nur an
Dach über den Kopf und dann wird
irgendwo da sitzt die Bildungsministerin
wir brauchen die Lehrer wir brauchen die
kita-betreuer wir brauchen all diese
Menschen die Gesundheitsversorgung die
kinderversicherung wir haben diese Leute
schlicht und ergreifend nicht
die ideologische Verhärtung verbringen
bitte an die Krankenversicherung
die Art und Weise wie wir diskutieren
sehr wenig pragmatisch wir haben Sie
Freunde
es ist nicht nur sehr wenig pragmatisch
es ist zum Teil ja auch
erschreckend was gemacht wird also wir
haben wir haben ja diesen Vorschlag
gehabt dass
Angehörige von
Clans mit abgeschoben werden können und
der Vorschlag der dort gemacht worden
ist ist in jeder Hinsicht vernünftig und
ganz
entspricht dem Gesetz was aber eine
Minute später daraus gemacht wurde ist
nicht Angehörige eine kriminellen
Vereinigung sondern
Familienangehörige und dann war das
Tod mit einem Mann was ein vollkommener
Blödsinn ist also alles was gesagt wird
oder sehr vieles was gesagt wird wird
eine Minute später
zu etwas vollkommen anderen verkehrt und
dann wird sich darüber aufgeregt und der
ursprüngliche Vorschlag der in jeder
Hinsicht vernünftig ist und übrigens
auch gar nichts ändern würde wenn man
das mal ernsthaft anschaut
existiert danach nicht mehr und das ist
das eigentlich gefährliche dass wir
mittlerweile eine eine Art und Weise
haben miteinander zu sprechen und über
Themen übereinander aufzusprechen die
die nur noch aus Reiz und Reaktionen
besteht aber nicht mehr aus nachdenken
und vor sich zurücktreten